while a formal announcement has still
yet to be made Activision has previously
confirmed that a sequel to destiny is on
the way now the rumor mill is working
overtime and dang it's sounding good I'm
Lucy and welcome to your oh my god it
might be coming to PC gamespot news
update a post on NeoGAF alleges the
Destiny sequel will be released for pc
which you'll remember the first game was
not additionally Skylanders developer
Vicarious Visions and Deadpool studio
high moon studios will reportedly assist
with the development while dubious on
its own kotaku has since corroborated
this reporting that it too has heard
word of a pc version and involvement
from vicarious high moon and other
studios it also adds in some other
details about what we can expect from
the game among these is the fact that a
reorganization took place at bungie in
april leading to a reboot of destiny to
story it's also aiming to have the game
feel like a proper sequel rather than
another expansion which could mean
forcing players to leave behind their
characters they would however
potentially receive some sort of bonuses
which would hardly be unprecedented with
a game like this additionally one of the
new features in destiny 2 is something
called play in destinations which kotaku
says would aspire to provide more
populated towns outposts and quests than
what's seen in Destiny's patrol missions
Bungie fans have been asking for a pc
version of destiny since prior to its
release back in 2013 the studio talked
about the challenge of releasing on four
platforms simultaneously which you
remember our ps4 xbox one ps3 and
xbox360 and how they didn't want to
spread themselves so thin that it
negatively harms the other platforms
notably though the new rise of iron
expansion dropped support for Xbox 360
and ps3 allowing Bungie to do things it
otherwise could not without those older
systems to worry about it sent a reason
that more resources could be put towards
a PC version so what would you like to
see in a destiny sequel let me know in
the comments below or come find me on
Twitter I'm at Lucy James games for more
on destiny make sure you keep it
spot